JOSH LIVNI: Hi, everybody.
My name is Joshua Livni.
I'm on the Maps Developer
Relations Team.
And we have a guest
here today.
Peter Birch works here as
Project Manager for Earth,
Earth API, and various
related products.
He's been here quite a
while and has all the
inside info on Earth.
So I thought it would be fun to
start out today's Hangout
with just some questions
maybe about the early
days of Google Earth.
I think you joined back
when it was Version 4.
It has come a long
way from then.
Maybe you can talk about some
of those early days.
PETER BIRCH: Yeah sure.
So I actually joined in 2006.
And I actually came in just
before what was the first Geo
Developer Day.
I don't know if you remember
that but--
JOSH LIVNI: I was there.
PETER BIRCH: Yes, that was sort
of the precursor to what
has now grown into Google I/O.
So I jumped in right in the
thick of it as we were starting
to get the first
version of Google Earth 4 out.
JOSH LIVNI: I think that's
when we introduced
superoverlays, I recall.
PETER BIRCH: That was.
JOSH LIVNI: I remember hacking
on a little Python script to
create some master
superoverlays.
Those were the days.
So things have come a
long way from there.
Maybe you can mention some of
the biggest changes that have
happened in the last few
years, the ones that
really stuck out.
PETER BIRCH: Yeah, certainly.
So Earth has gone through
this progression.
So it started off as a
Windows desktop app.
We added Mac support in
3.1, I believe, which
was before my time.
We introduced Linux support.
But since then, there's been
a lot of big changes.
So obviously, the introduction
of the Earth API in 2008 was
really one big change in the
way of bringing that
experience to the web and
really creating another
developer community in addition
to what could be done
with KML, being able to use
JavaScript to control Earth.
The other big change obviously
is mobile.
We launched, again
in 2008, the iOS.
So at the time, it was
the first iPhone.
Since then, we've added
obviously Android, we've added
iPads, and Android tablets.
So there's been a lot.
I think everyone's pretty
aware there's just been
tremendous growth in mobile.
And that Geo kind of things,
whether it's maps or location
information, is such an integral
part of the mobile
experience that it's really
an exciting space for us.
So we've been spending lot of
time kind of thinking about
mobile as well.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, and I think
it's the latest 6.2.2 version
that has some new-found
abilities with KML in mobile.
Maybe you just want
to talk briefly a
little bit about that.
PETER BIRCH: Yeah, I mean, when
we first came out with
Earth on mobile, everyone's
first question was when can I
have KML displaying on it?
And I think that what we knew
at the time was that we're
actually sharing a lot of the
same code between these
different devices.
But obviously, a mobile device
is a more constrained
environment.
And so it took us some time,
first of all, to expand on to
multiple platforms and make
sure we worked on tablets.
And then there were some other
just general things we needed
to do to make sure that KML
would work successfully.
But we're really excited to
finally be able to turn that
on in 6.2 and have that
available simultaneously on
iOS devices and Android
devices.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, it was really
nice to work with the
KML and have it load right up
in the native application.
And it had some pretty
robust stories.
Tours look great on the tablet
devices, look amazing.
PETER BIRCH: Yeah, I was really
excited to get Tours in
there as well.
I think it was really important
to us to really
support KML and the
KML developers.
Because there's just so much KML
out there that we really
wanted to make it so you didn't
have to create this
mobile only experience or some
other kind of thing.
So that basically if you have
KML linked off of your page
somewhere, you can click on
that, download it, and do it.
And I think that really just
expands the existing community
of Geo developers and people
who are using KML without
having to create something
that's kind of slightly
different and new.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, and the other
one I want to recognize
is if you have a Tour in the KML
and then in your tablet or
phone, it just brings up that
play automatically.
That's pretty intuitive.
PETER BIRCH: Yeah, it's
something we're actually
experimenting with.
In some ways, the mobile
platform gives us a little
more leeway to experiment
because there's not as much
past usage and expectations.
So we are able to play around
with the things a little bit
differently.
So that was one of things where
we wanted to try that
out and see if it works.
So the fact that you have a
Tour, you load it up, you
immediately start playing it,
may be an idea that we carry
back over to the desktop.
Because I know that a lot
of people who do Tour
development, you end up with
this awkward double click here
on the icon on the left-hand
panel, not very intuitive for
users that aren't necessarily
familiar with KML.
So we're looking at ways of
making it an easier, more
fluid experience for everyone.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, I love that
latest. It's fun to play on
the tablet for sure.
But going back to something
you said earlier about the
Earth API, we had Paul
Rademacher on a few weeks ago.
I know he worked on the early
API, but we didn't talk about
that so much.
Do you have fun stories
of how that started?
Anything interesting that the
general public might not know
about the early, early days
of the Earth API?
PETER BIRCH: I think the fact
that Paul worked on it is a
pretty interesting fun fact.
JOSH LIVNI: Because he came from
the Maps background with
the mashup.
PETER BIRCH: Yeah, so, I mean,
he sort of was the guy who
created Google Maps API
in some ways, right?
So basically Google Maps was
out there with its housing
maps, basically hacked it in
such a way that he actually
started to mash up
his own map.
In this case, it was like
Craigslist data with our maps.
And so, we were really excited
when he did join Google and
really wanted to work on Earth
API and bringing the 3D
experience in.
He has a background in
3D graphics as well.
So that was pretty cool.
It was kind of like someone
coming in who both had the 3D
animation experience
and who was sort
of one of the pioneers--
JOSH LIVNI: Pioneering
what a mashup is.
PETER BIRCH: --in creating a
mashup as the driving force
behind getting the
Earth API built.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, yeah, and
we've seen a lot of adoption
since then.
So I guess just a couple more
questions before we go to
open-ended questions here from
folks on our moderator.
If you are watching that live
stream on YouTube, you're
welcome to click the link
in our + page to
ask a moderator question.
Otherwise, we'll gather some
more questions from the folks
in the Hangout as well.
So just a couple of
quick questions.
What's your favorite app that
you've seen recently that
people have developed
on the API?
PETER BIRCH: So I'm a big fan,
of course, of Paul van Dinther
his work on PlanetInAction.
JOSH LIVNI: Beautiful stuff.
PETER BIRCH: Always great to see
what he's coming up with.
And the most recent one, which
is the ocean current
animation, is just
really stunning.
It's actually based on some data
that NOAA put together,
so it's satellite-based
high-resolution time-sequence
imagery of currents.
And like any great Geo data, it
gets even better when you
actually put it on
Google Earth.
Being able to--
JOSH LIVNI: Really see those
patterns globally.
PETER BIRCH: And if you go to
planetinaction.com, you can go
in there and play with
it yourself.
Doing it on a Hangout probably
won't do it justice to the
experience.
But it really is a great way of
actually visualizing real
scientific data, which
is the sort of
perpetual current patterns.
And you can actually fly around
the Earth and see them.
You can see different
eddies occurring.
You can really start to
understand what marine
navigation was like in the day
when people were trying to
figure out how do they get from
one place to another.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah,
it's amazing.
PETER BIRCH: I'm a
sailor as well.
So it's always interesting
seeing how our planet is
moving around and churning.
And that's a great visualization
of it.
JOSH LIVNI: It would be
interesting to overlay some
SID tracks and pop in those even
today and see how much
they take advantage of the
different currents.
All right, next mashup.
And what about some new
data that we've
added to Google Earth?
I know we keep adding lots of
different data all the time.
What are some of your favorite
tasks with new data additions?
PETER BIRCH: So probably my
favorite one we've done
recently is part of our
historical imagery.
We've recently added--
so I live in San Francisco.
And we recently added 1938 San
Francisco imagery, which is
just fantastic.
So the historical imagery
feature in general has always
been one of my favorite features
that people don't
necessarily know about
because there's
just such a vast archive.
We're always bringing in
new imagery, and we're
laying it on top.
And we're covering up a lot
of what was there before.
So the fact that when we
introduced it in Earth 5, this
ability to be able to kind of
peel back and go back in time
is tremendously powerful.
Now we're starting to
turn up these data
sets like this 1938.
It's one-meter resolution
imagery
of all of San Francisco.
It's incredibly high resolution,
and you can, for
those of you who know San
Francisco, have been there,
it's really fantastic.
You can go and look at Crissy
Field, which now it's like a
park and marine wetlands area
that used to be an airstrip.
So you can actually see
it as an airstrip.
You can see planes on it.
You can see the hangars.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah,
the waterfront,
there's just so much.
PETER BIRCH: Yeah,
and it's funny.
You can see what hasn't
changed as well.
So it's a great data set.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, definitely
take advantage of the
historical imagery when you're
browsing on Google Earth.
But also if you're
a developer, take
advantage of that, too.
If you're telling a story that
takes place over a period of
time, you can programmatically
disable and enable historical
imagery and choose what
era you're looking at.
PETER BIRCH: And that's
something we have in
the Earth API today.
It's not something we have on
mobile yet, but it's obviously
something that we've
thought about.
Because being able to bring
that kind of experience to
wherever you are I think would
be pretty powerful.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, it's amazing
to see how the Earth changes.
So we should probably move on
to some live questions here.
I'm going to go ahead
for those of you--
I've muted everybody who joined
this Office Hours.
Can you raise your hand if
you have a question?
I'll unmute you and be happy to
answer any questions that
we can here.
All right we have a question
here from Don.
Let me figure out how
to unmute you.
I think you're open.
AUDIENCE: I'm just curious about
the future of Google
Earth on mobile and whether or
not that's going to be a
platform where developers and
what we've been able to do
with the Earth API are going
to be able to do anything
similar at all in
terms of mobile?
PETER BIRCH: Sure.
So that's a great question.
So the first part of that, I
think, is the 6.2 release is
really kind of the first
step towards that.
So prior to that, there was
really no way for anyone to
customize or put data on it.
So we're starting by saying
use your existing KML.
Any data that you have, you
can view that on a map.
And there's really quite a
lot you can do with that.
So not only can you just take
existing KML data, you also
can use Tours.
So basically, if you have a
Tour in your data, you not
only can have the data there,
but you can have the whole
visualization for it and the
fact that, as Josh mentioned,
we'll go ahead and auto
launch the player.
There's also another interesting
little feature in
there, which is we have
something called a Tour
Generator, where we will
auto-generate a Tour.
And I think we need to get some
documentation up for this
on the dev site, because
you can actually pass
in an ID for a feature.
And then Google Earth will
auto-generate the best Tour it
can based on that data.
And we'll be talking some
more about that later.
We need to get some--
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, a nice
KML article on that.
That's a great idea.
PETER BIRCH: And in fact,
we're using it in the My
Tracks app right now.
So if you go off and say, go for
a bike ride, and then you
want to say, hey, I want to view
this, you can hit play.
It will launch Earth.
Earth will automatically
generate a Tour for it and
then will replay it.
So that's step one.
Is there going to be another
stage where you can have a
complete full-API control?
And it's definitely something
I'd like to see happen.
We don't have anything to
talk about right now.
And we need to think about what
the right platform is.
We have to think about
Android and iOS.
So the JavaScript API, given the
restrictions of plug-ins,
means that there isn't a great
story there right now.
But I definitely see
us moving in that
direction in the long term.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks guys.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, thank you.
Any other questions
from folks here?
We got one here, and then we'll
hop over to our moderator.
Let's see, can we hear
you, Jeremy?
AUDIENCE: It's a Street View
question, actually.
We have a site called the
Best Driving Roads.
And it's an interactive thing.
It's KML overlaid on
top of Google Maps.
What are the chances of at
some point in the future
people being able to drive along
through Street View?
So you're making Street View
images into a movie.
So you could go along stage
by stage by stage.
It would be a jaggedy movie,
but it would flow
you down the road.
PETER BIRCH: It's an
interesting idea.
I think that within the API--
I don't know what things on the
Maps API side people have
done with transitions from
Street View image to Street
View image.
Certainly within Earth API, we
already have the ability, at
least some limited capabilities,
of moving the
camera, and Earth will sort of
automatically update the--
JOSH LIVNI: Kind of
interpolate it.
PETER BIRCH: Does the
interpolation between them.
So that's something that might
be worth playing around with.
I don't know if you have
any familiarity on
the Maps API side.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, the Earth API
does have a much smoother
animation with some pretty
complex interpolation that we
do inside of Earth, and
it's quite nice.
On the Maps API side, that's
certainly getting better with
the HTML5 version of Street
View looking a lot more
smoother between these
discrete steps.
It's not a smooth--
really video yet.
So I think that's a really good
feature request-- and
we've heard it before-- to try
make a smoother animation as
you navigate through
Street View.
And that's I think--
AUDIENCE: I think it's
not just us.
I think all sorts of people
could use a way of moving
across the landscape,
couldn't they?
PETER BIRCH:Yeah, I mean,
there's a couple of ways that
it could be approached.
One is the one that we've
talked about, which is
basically moving your
virtual camera
through a series of panos.
And there'd be some kind of
transition as you move from
one to the next to the next.
The other one would be some kind
of offline rendering of a
video for a given sequence,
which would obviously involve
a different set of
infrastructure on our side
where we'd actually try to
create that video on demand
and then be able to
play it back.
That would be pretty
cool, though.
JOSH LIVNI: Actually, that's
a very cool idea.
AUDIENCE: For instance, we
could do it ourselves.
We could take a section of the
roads and put that together so
we have it on.
But you guys don't like us
taking this stuff on board, do
you, and having it
on our side?
I know it's just the
nature of Google.
JOSH LIVNI: Yes, so definitely
our terms don't allow you to
do offline analysis on the
Street View imagery.
Also, another pretty common
feature request, though.
So it's not that
we ignore them.
We definitely--
AUDIENCE: No, I understand,
yeah.
JOSH LIVNI: --look at people's
questions for that.
We try see if we can build a
service that would do the
things that are needed, but
case in point noted.
And I think there's actually
open feature requests for that
on the Maps API issue tracker.
And if you go there and you
star those, the more
developers that star those
things, the more they pop up
on our radar every time we have
a meeting and say what
should we do next to make this a
better developer experience.
The more people clamor for
something, the more likely it
is to happen.
So that is really
good feedback.
AUDIENCE: Pulling off that,
how many many stars do you
need for something
to really figure?
Do you need like 20 stars or--
JOSH LIVNI: Definitely
more than one.
Unless there's a really good
point on that one.
PETER BIRCH: There's also
obviously a trade off between--
there's a full spectrum
of different
types of feature requests.
There's things that are
basically just a bug that we
haven't got to yet that
might be fairly
straightforward to fix.
There are things that we may
already have been working on,
and it's just a matter
of like, OK,
well, now it's ready.
There might be things that we
hadn't thought of before, but
actually are fairly
easy for us to do.
And then there are things that
may be great ideas, but they
also involve a pretty
significant amount of work.
And in those cases, those things
take longer or we may
or may not get to them.
So unfortunately, there's not
a straightforward answer.
JOSH LIVNI: Sort of an
engineering effort.
But if you look, for example,
just today, I think we put out
a blog post on the Geo developer
blog about a bunch
of new features in
our Places API.
And all of those features, I
can assure you, were driven
entirely by user requests
on the issue tracker.
And we looked at the top
requests, and we implemented
those for the Places API.
So this happens all the time.
We definitely look at that.
It's a great way to give us
feedback about what's
important to you guys.
PETER BIRCH: And it keeps us
from going off and spending
time doing stuff that you
guys don't care about.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, but at the
same time, there are ones that
would require just
disproportionate effort , or
for various other reasons,
we just can't do them.
And then even a large number
of stars might not get you
what you're looking for.
We try to give you feedback
when that's
going to happen, though.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MODERATOR: Should we jump
on this right here?
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, let's hop into
some moderator questions,
and then we'll come back here
for a quick last question or
two if there are any.
I'm just going to go ahead and
mute all of these screens.
And I'll share the screen here
so we can all see these
moderator questions.
There we go.
OK, wow, that was pretty cool.
Oh yes, let's go to
the top question.
"What is Google's
plan with Google
Earth Desktop and plug-in?
With Sketchup being sold and a
growing aversion to plug-ins,
I cannot help but wonder if it
is the end of Google Earth?
Is that in sight?"
PETER BIRCH: Absolutely not.
So basically plug-ins are the
worst solution ever, except
for all the others.
I think plug-ins are something
that are really
a means to an end.
And no, I hate plug-ins
as well.
And I think the real question
is, given what we're trying to
do and all the functionality
with the high frame rate 3D
graphics, what's the best
way to bring that to
developers on the web?
And that answer has been and
continues to be using our
plug-in to provide
that capability.
Now, obviously, there's
some really
exciting stuff going on.
In the web world now there's
a lot of things with--
JavaScript is getting faster
and faster all the time.
There's worker threads.
WebGL is showing a lot
of great promise
with our Maps TL.
It's sort of an indication
of our commitment to that
technology and our commitment
to really push the limits of
the web as a platform.
So we're absolutely looking at
ways to further bring together
an immersive 3D environment
and the web.
And it's hard to know how that's
going to play out and
when it's going to play out.
Obviously, we're very
interested in WebGL.
We're looking at it.
But today, it really takes the
plug-in to provide the full
breadth of functionality that we
want to have. But overall,
we're very committed to mapping
out the world and
providing this virtual
3D experience.
And I think over the years, what
that means in terms of
technology is going to
evolve and change.
I mean, five years ago we
wouldn't have thought about
mobile device as even
being a factor.
And yet here we are, and mobile
is a critical part of
our products, our stories,
our developers.
Everyone wants to know
how mobile is going
to play into it.
What are things going to look
like five years from now?
I don't know yet.
But we're committed to really
creating the best experience
we can on whatever platforms
our users are on.
JOSH LIVNI: You don't
know what's going to
happen in five years?
PETER BIRCH: Well, I do.
I just can't say it.
JOSH LIVNI: You're right.
You can't share that
information today.
So let's hop back up to
this next window.
We have--
it's just coming into focus.
"How are applications chosen
or considered for the
developer showcase?"
PETER BIRCH: Josh.
JOSH LIVNI: Yes.
So we have our new developer
channel at
developers.google.com.
And one of the things there is
a pretty nice showcase that
includes a whole lot of Maps
and Earth, sort of the
best-in-breed out.
So how does your app get
on there and how
do we choose them?
The short answer is, it's a
curated list. We go over and
we look at things that have
caught our attention one way
or another that we think show
off some of the cool
capabilities, like a really nice
styled map, an amazing
tour in Earth, what have you.
And then we also pay attention
to what people are talking
about online on different
social networks.
And then obviously, if you guys
have something that you'd
like to submit or that you think
is great, whether it's
your own or somebody else's, you
can hit over our + page,
the Maps API Google+ page, and
let us know about it there.
We'll take a look, and we try
to refresh the ones that are
on there periodically.
Make sure there are nice, new
examples that are taking
advantage of compelling
features so that other
developers can come and say,
well, I didn't really know you
could do that.
Or that's a great way to do
that thing that I used do.
PETER BIRCH: What about more
Earth API examples?
JOSH LIVNI: There are
so many out there.
We have a lot.
That's a good point.
OK, I pledge we'll get one
or two up this week.
I'll take another look.
Well, that PlanetInAction one
you mentioned was amazing.
PETER BIRCH: Well, there's a
whole bunch of other ones that
I'd like to see up
there as well.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, so as you can
see, it's a very formal
process here.
But definitely let us know
if you have something.
We kind of try to curate a list
that we think is just
going to be compelling
for developers to
learn something from.
So this next question.
OK, so "rotating ground overlays
in Google Maps API,
can it be done?" So this is a
question, I think, by Paul van
Dinther, who we mentioned
earlier.
And it was asked also
on Stack Overflow.
And there's not a
comment here.
I'll try to add a comment to
this moderator later, but we
answered that.
The short answer is yes,
absolutely you can.
Brendon on our team posted some
working code sample that
shows you just how to do that.
So absolutely you can use canvas
rotation, no problem.
Next question.
Feature request--
a set of design patterns, best
practices for data biz on the
mobile, on the desktop discovery
sort of based on--
I'm guessing--
what our UX and engineers think
are the best way to go.
I shouldn't be bring
that up yet.
It's a really good question.
I'm going to bring us out of
the screen share here.
So I think that's a
fantastic idea.
And we should absolutely
do that.
I'll let you answer, then I'll
add some more detail there.
PETER BIRCH: Yeah, I mean, I'd
love to see that, too.
I think the thing that is
changing this equation as well
is the fact that Earth has been
a desktop large screen
application for a long time.
So I think, at least from a KML
perspective, people have
built some of their own kind
of best practices.
But we really haven't talked
about like if you're going to
put a legend up, where do you
put it on the screen, and a
lot of those kind of things.
And now with the transition to
mobile, things got a lot more
complicated.
You've got to worry
about phones.
about tablets.
You've got to worry about
portrait mode and landscape
mode, and that really
complicates the UI.
And we see that ourselves in
the application development
that there's not like a
one pattern fits all.
And it also depends on what
type of application do you
have. Do you really need
a legend there?
What's the right way
to present it?
I'd love to see that.
JOSH LIVNI: I mean, generally
on Android, it's always good
to follow the standard best
practices that the average
person who used all kinds of
apps on the phone are going to
be familiar with.
And I know that the Android
guys have--
I think they call it Android
University--
a lot of best practices
there and examples.
You can follow folks
like Roman Nurik.
He used to actually work a lot
with Google Earth over on the
Android team.
And he's a great designer, and
I think he posts links to a
lot of the best practices for
layout and ways to build your
app with that in mind.
But more generally, I think
it's a great idea.
A lot of our examples right now
say, here's how you get
started here is the best way to
enable ground overlays or a
sidebar or something.
But then we don't really take
that next step and what's the
whole screen space going
to look like?
What's the whole application
going to look like?
And yeah, I think we could
probably put together some
compelling stuff with our UX
guys and maybe post a couple
of good articles out there,
so great feedback.
PETER BIRCH: For Earth API, it'd
be good to know how to
handle embedded in a page versus
going to a full-screen
mode and some things to consider
for that as well.
JOSH LIVNI: Absolutely.
Yeah, we've seen a lot of people
implement the left-hand
panel for the Earth API
in different ways.
I really like that open source
KML tree application.
But more generally,
yeah, exactly.
We could put out some best
practices there.
I think that's an
excellent plan.
Where are we here?
"How much does Google Maps and
Earth inform Google insights?"
PETER BIRCH: Is that insights
with a capital I or a
lowercase I?
JOSH LIVNI: Well, here
it's a lowercase.
But that could mean anything.
PETER BIRCH: How does it
inform Google insights?
Well, I'll just sort of think
about it generically.
I mean, obviously, location
information is a really core
part of everything.
And I think that Google is a
search company, and we're all
about making information in
the world universally
accessible and useful.
Location is a really key part
of the world's information.
If you think about it,
everything that has happened
somewhere in the world--
everything we've ever done has
happened somewhere on this
world, if you exclude
space travel.
So the location component
is such a critical part.
We already are working on
surfacing local data and other
things as part of Google
search itself.
I think of location as being
yet another search term in
anything that you might
want to do.
Especially for our Google Maps
for mobile, if you're out on
the town and you want to know
about a bar, for example, you
probably want to know about
the ones that are walking
distance from you.
And so this idea of really
making sure that location is
tied in with the broader Google
experience is something
that I think is really
important.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah,
I agree 100%.
And unfortunately, I'm
not entirely sure--
are either of you the people
who asked that question?
May we ask for a
clarification?
No?
OK.
Well, we'll move to
the next question.
Hopefully, that was the
intended question.
And the last question we have
"when will Google Earth get
Google+ layer to display?
And will there be a separate
later to display pictures from
Picaso Web and G+?" I think some
overlays on top of Earth
are being requested.
PETER BIRCH: Sure.
So I think it's a great idea.
I mean, obviously, the key part
is to make sure that you
have information and
the location.
And that's something that I need
to look further into to
say is there feed available that
basically is a location
tag stream of posts.
But I think that would
be fantastic.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, and I have
seen some mashups out there of
people who use the public G+ API
to read in check-ins, for
example, where those occurred.
That's certainly the type
of thing you could do.
Could we make it a little
bit more robust or
potentially show you--
I mean, certainly with Earth
API, you could do it today.
But I think that is an
interesting idea.
There's a lot of good content
being shared out there.
PETER BIRCH: Yeah, I
think that's great.
JOSH LIVNI: OK, cool.
So I think we're done.
Does anyone in the live
Hangout here have any
last-minute questions?
Looking good.
OK, well, thanks for joining
us everyone.
We really appreciate it.
Peter, thank you very much
for joining us this week.
PETER BIRCH: My pleasure.
JOSH LIVNI: And I think
we have another
one next week scheduled.
I will post a link to the exact
time, probably 1:00 PM
Pacific Time.
We were a little early
this week.
And thanks again.